dominic champagne metteur en scène
initiateurs surtout du pacte vers la
transition est donc avec une nouvelle
carte de membre dominic champagne
bonsoir et écouter qu'est ce qui vous a
motivé finalement de prendre cette carte
de membre 5
on a décidé d'en faire vraiment un
mouvement non partisan et il s'est avéré
que je pense qu'elle est allée à la
rencontre de tous les partis politiques
est une chose importante à leur chalet
rencontrer le caucus des libéraux le
caucus des péquistes les solidaires et à
un moment donné je me suis dit tu y es
sachant voyant venir que la caq allait
être en mode rattrapage sur sur la
plateforme l'environnement me suis dit
tiens je vais prendre ma carte et je
vais aller à c y et d'inspirer de
l'intérieur donc le d'état pour ja pb
d'état pour souffrir à la voile alors en
fin de semaine j'ai aussi de souffler
dans la voile de la cac qui visiblement
est sensible à la mobilisation
importante qu'on a connus depuis des
mois je pense qu'on venait parler de ce
qui se passait dans les rues en europe
je pense que les scientifiques nous ont
parlé une semaine après l'élection de
l'accueil le rapport du giec la nature
nous parle par les temps qui courent la
jeunesse nous parle
la mobilisation citoyenne ou parler là
je pense le parti quitte tout pouvoir
est à l'écouté
alors on a essayé de te prendre la main
de l'aider à marcher puis de lui et
supplient les meilleurs avec
persévérance patience persuasion vous
allez déchirer votre carte
non j'ai promis un lait je pense les
gens de la cac qui était un peu nerveux
aussi de me voir arriver je leur ai dit
écoutez vous jouez en pole à kiel
congrès de laquelle on pas faire mon
show les fans et les panélistes et puis
j'irai sûrement comme membre essayer de
proposer un amendement je pourrais me
présenter au micro pour demain à chacune
des propositions proposé un amendement
ou une contre-proposition ça serait viré
le congrès dans un rapport de force
entre le pacte pour la transition et la
caq ce que je ne ferai pas je les ai
rassurés je leur ai dit que j'allais
faire mon point en même temps on m'a
offert cette tribune n'a donc je vais
aller parler aux militants mais voilà la
bord où elle est bravo 2
de faire ce pas là en même temps il faut
s'assurer que pour 2030 la crise est
telle que c'est important qu'on a une
volonté politique forte parce que c'est
normal de tranchant sans fond si vous
souffler dans le cou du premier ministre
du ministre environnement et que vous
n'avez pas de réponse vous pouvez la
déchirer cette carte là éventuellement
je sais qu'il va toucher quoi la raison
mon engagement c'est que une semaine
après l'élection de la caq au québec la
démocratie a parlé et lille élus le
parti qui était le dernier de classe en
environnement selon les groupes
environnementaux une semaine après on ne
leur a pas dit et qui nous dit on à de
10 à 12 ans pour agir
dix à douze ans la c2 trois mandats de
la cac
c'est eux qui sont au pouvoir
présentement c'est eux qui ont le devoir
le mandat d'atteindre les cibles et je
pense qu'on a une grande corvée
nationale à faire le gouvernement il y
arrivera pas tout seul alors un homme de
bonne volonté j'essaie de faire en sorte
que l'on puisse dire nous sommes là le
pacs est l'idée l'idée c'est de dire on
voit individuellement femmes pas mais il
faut que les politiques publiques
suivant les jours prendre plusieurs
exemples d'ailleurs j'ai reçu le premier
nice le go via les lignes
cette semaine était à washington je lui
ai posé une question voici questions
réponses avec le premier ministre nous
parlait depuis washington ce week-end
vous allez recevoir à votre conseil
général dominic champagne
l'auteur du fameux pacte qui a dénoncé
d'ailleurs le troisième lien déjà avec
québec
est-ce qu' il n'y ait pas un risque pour
vous de souffler le chaud et le froid
c'est à dire de vente et les urnes et
géré les énergies renouvelables en
voulant développer un troisième lien à
l'est qui soulève la controverse et qui
est pas s'inscrit pas dans une politique
de développement durable semble-t-il en
tout cas pour ceux qui cire repos vous
avez vous des choses à répondre déjà
2000 champagne oui je pense que au
québec c'est important d'avoir un
équilibre et si on va avoir l'appui de
la population
c'est important d'avoir un équilibre moi
je veut s'engager à ce que jamais un
gouvernement n'aura fait autant que le
gouvernement de la cac pour réaliser des
projets de transport en commun on est
plusieurs à montréal sur la rive nord
sur la rive sud de montréal à gatineau à
québec un projet de tramway qui est
important par contre il ya des régions
où il n'y a pas une densité de
population suffisante pour
mettre en place des transports en commun
donc faut avoir des erreurs c'est
qu'entre autres pour
chaudière-appalaches où les gens ont
besoin de ce troisième lien donc pour
moi c'est important l'equilibre ça ne
m'empêchera pas de pousser pour avoir le
plus rapidement possible de tramway le
projet structurant québec commentaire
j'entends le premier ministre parlait d'
équilibre je pense qu'il va y avoir
rapidement une espèce de devoir de
cohérence new york décide d'être
carboneutre et on appelle à la rescousse
ses irréductibles au dehors de la carte
qui ont de la potion magique plein les
portes et françois legault en bon
voyageur de commerce de ils y arrivent
en cours à new york en juin voici nous
sommes là nous sommes les détenteurs
d'un trésor énergétique extraordinaire
alors je pense qu'il ya des leçons à
tirer le québec doit aussi aussi le
devoir de se mettre carboneutre on a des
ressources en électricité extraordinaire
donc il faut orienter notre économie va
pour la sortir du carbone n'est pas les
enfoncer donc ça va être difficile pour
le gouvernement d'avoir le pari on parle
d'équilibré je pense que plus surtout à
devoir de cohérence donc il faut soit au
sens fort
on continue de s'enfoncer dans le
pétrole et en gaz soit s'en retire au
québec on a des atouts pour le faire et
je pense que là on va arriver rapidement
à la croisée des chemins de vie lors des
choix importants lors des choix mais
c'est un premier qui parle à ses
électeurs aussi la région de québec
c'est important ils parlent pour sa
population
malgré les rapports qui est un succès
plus à l'ouest
je comprends la science quand ça
présente affaire et pas qu'en voile
alors au pacs et on a rapidement dit il
faut mettre la raison scientifique le
gros bon sens l'humanité au coeur des
décisions collectives alors est-ce qu'on
va se plier à un lobby puissant celui
des radios 2d québec notamment celui de
l'industrie du pétrole qui veut
continuer à porter le le comportement de
l'auto solo ou bien est ce qu'on va
trouver des solutions modernes pour
régler le problème de la congestion
québec par exemple mais les questions
vont se poser aussi avec le projet de
gazoduc au saguenay le projet d'une
jean de durée à bécancour il ya des
projets qui sont hautement émetteur de
gaz à effet de serre et là le
gouvernement va devoir avoir un
leadership réel et faire preuve de
cohérence
écoutons le ministre eric girard en
alberta cette semaine on écoute ça fait
partie des projets communs où le québec
et l'alberta serait gagnant gagnant 14
milliards d'investissements c'est
extrêmement positif pour le québec
ça permettrait d'exporter 10 % du gaz
naturel qui est produit au canada
alors c'est un projet qui
gagnant-gagnant oui nous en avons parlé
donc en ont parlé le québec accepterait
ça alors qu'ils refuseraient donc un
pipeline pour du pétrole
alors qu'aujourd'hui dans l'ouest ont
dit les provinces autres que la copie
danic ne pas bloquer un pipeline et
beaucoup d'enjeu là il ya beaucoup
d'enjeu mais je pense fondamentalement
ce qu'il faut ce dire si la science
aujourd'hui nous dit il faut réduire de
moitié d'ici 10 ans d'ici 2030
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dont le principal responsable c'est le
pétrole et le gaz
alors soit on continue de s'enfoncer
dans le pétrole et le gaz ils ont
contribué à la dégradation du monde en
quelle envie soit environ néons fait la
transition vers pas ici avec près de
vire et donc c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'il ya un devoir de cohérence
autrement le premier nice le goût au
risque de se retrouver en même situation
on se retrouve aujourd'hui justin
trudeau qui ont adopté des mesures
progressistes une taxe sur le carbone
d'un investissement les infrastructures
mais qui par ailleurs nous ont rendu les
heureux copropriétaire d'un pipeline
dont l'industrie elle-même ne voulait
pas pour continuer à accroître la
production la distribution la combustion
du pétrole soit disant parce que c'est
de la création de richesses et la voix
de notre prospérité or c'est ça qui
dégradent notre monde est aujourd'hui
justin trudeau
il y a de la difficulté à se présenter
aux prochaines élections en réel
aujourd'hui c'est bon là on appelle le
ghanéen tribunaux on voit qu'une vague
bleue
très très forte qui souffre et qui
risquent en fait de le sortir du pouvoir
parce que tout à coup son devoir de y'a
pas été assez cohérent dans sa politique
alors moi je mets en garde le
gouvernement le goût d'une part de faire
de vanter les mérites de notre trésor
hydroélectriques et de toutes les vertus
qu'on peut tirer de l'innovation de
l'efficacité énergétique au québec
mais par ailleurs de nous enfoncer
davantage dans le gaz naturel soit
disant naturel faut pas oublier que le
gaz de gnl convoi liquéfié c'est très
majoritairement du gaz de schiste au
québec on a décidé de dire non au gaz de
schiste alors pourquoi l'autre thakoon
un portrait du poison soi disant parce
que 14 milliards d'investissements mais
à qui ça profite au bout du compte des
investissements l'homme parfait qui vous
pas les intérêts très puissant du lobby
du pétrole et du gaz qui en impose
visiblement parfois plus fort que la
démocratie carte de membre de la cac et
vous pourriez faire le même geste à
l'égard du parti libéral du canada elle
est carrément chez les libéraux fédéraux
reproduire ce geste qui sait je pense
que le gouvernement trudeau s'il veut se
réhabiliter vos dover devoir faire
preuve d'une grande audace
est-ce que ils vont incapable après que
les albertains est votée très clairement
récemment d'isabelle à nous le deal
qu'on a fait avec le fédéral sur le
marché du carbone sur la taxation du
carbone le plafond qu'on a qu'on accepte
et on va déchirer cette entente là alors
est-ce que ce qui est trop tard pour
trudeau de vraiment se poser en champion
du climat à l'heure où il faut répondre
à l'appel de la science répondent à ce
que la nature nous d'y répondre à la
jeunesse qui prend la rue qui est
inquiète qu'elle doit un avenir viable
la question est posée peut-être que la
prochaine carte de membre que je devrais
prendre celle du parti libéral du canada
en attendant le parti vert fait des
progrès quand même pour informer
complètement le public du gouvernement
quand même fait des annonces aujourd'hui
en effet deux notamment sur de l'aide
pour l'installation de bornes
électriques dans des multi logements
donc c'est une mesure que jusqu'à 5000 $
dead snow jamais l'autre mesure annoncée
qui est monsieur legault pourrait
confirmer ces images c'est que tous les
nouveaux bâtiments gouvernementaux
d'oran serait avec de l'énergie propre a
fini le mazout
absolument je pense qu'au québec l'ont
en plus on sait qu'on est en surplus
alors il ya un usage beaucoup plus
intelligent beaucoup plus moderne qu'on
peut faire de nos ressources en énergie
beaucoup plus propre et celle du pétrole
et du gaz
alors le mot d'ordre c'est éloignons
nous du pétrole et du gaz et embrassons
les énergies renouvelables mais gêne
alors un geste du rapport ce que j'ai
mentionné du gouvernement dimanche
pour vous rendre heureux ou confiance
devrait dire annoncé une politique
claire où on va dire au québec
croire en nous mêmes c'est investir dans
les énergies propres et donc s'éloigner
nécessairement de tout projet pétrolier
et de tout projet quasi très bien merci
beaucoup de changements au conseil
général fait tu laisses tu prenais des
cartes de membres d'autres partis tandis
qu'elles sont quand même vous êtes papa
d'être récupérés moi je pense que je
chéris opérable mais ils peuvent mais ça
y est on
je suis prête à jouer le jeu vous allez
leur souffler dans le cou ça c'est
certain
ou dans les oreilles merci merci